hi everyone welcome to the homeroom live
stream very excited about the
conversation we're about to have but
before we jump into that i'll make a
couple of my standard announcements
first of all just a reminder that khan
academy is a not-for-profit organization
we can only exist through philanthropic
donations from folks like yourself so if
you're in a position to do so please
think about going to khan academy.org
donate i also want to give a special
shout out to several organizations
who've really stepped up when they
realized that khan academy was running
at a deficit even before the covet
crisis and during the crisis as you can
imagine our traffic is almost 300 of
normal our registrations are 10x of
normal we're trying to accelerate a
bunch of content and programs so special
thanks to bank of america google.org att
fastly novartis and the amgen foundation
and many other supporters uh who have
allowed khan academy to be in a position
to serve a lot of folks uh in this in
this time of need and beyond i also want
to make sure everyone knows if you want
to listen to these conversations maybe
in the car or some other place
you can get them homeroom with sal the
podcast
and and
you can find it any place where you can
find podcasts i believe
uh so with that i'm really excited to
introduce our guest
john king
john great to have you
glad to be here thanks thanks for
inviting me
it's a real honor uh john is uh sir
you've served as uh as secretary of
education under president obama you're
the president and ceo of the education
trust
there's so much i want to talk to you
about but before just everyone kind of
really understands the work that you do
now what what what does the education
trust do what is your focus
sure we're an education civil rights
organization so we work to ensure
equitable access to educational
opportunity particularly for low-income
students and students of color
and i want to encourage everyone given
that now what you know about
john
put your questions on youtube and
facebook and we have team members who
will surface it to myself and john over
the course of this conversation so john
maybe a good place to start given both
your work on in the obama administration
and the work that you do now
how are you viewing the crisis i i'd
argue we're facing an education right
now around the school closures how do
you think it's going to play out what do
you think we should be doing
yeah well we're in a disastrous
situation because the country
is in a disastrous situation the federal
government really failed to manage the
pandemic based on the science we still
don't have a coherent national strategy
around
rapid results testing around contact
tracing around
effective quarantine around
mass wearing and other public health
guidelines so in the absence of a
coherent national strategy we're left in
a situation uh where
uh schools are bearing the brunt of the
consequences and superintendents school
boards are an impossible situation of
trying to figure out how to serve kids
in a context where there's tremendous
community spread of covid19
the reality is many places will have to
be
distance or best hybrid and we're doing
that in the context where we still have
this huge digital divide i mean i don't
have to tell you the the pew study shows
79 percent of white families have
reliable internet access 66 percent of
black families 61 percent of latino
families the schoolhouse door is
literally barred for students because
they don't have the internet we have
gaps in access to devices we have gaps
in access to professional development
and support for teachers around doing
distance learning well
well-resourced districts have a ton of
support
under-resourced districts
disproportionately serving low-income
students and students of color don't
have those supports for teachers and we
see those consequences playing out you
know the last thing i mentioned is
there's a real socio-emotional toll to
school closure school is the place where
kids and and adults build
critically important relationships i was
a kid i
you know my life was saved by my
relationships at school
my mom passed when i was eight my dad
when i was twelve the thing that saved
me
was the reliability the consistency of
school and so my heart breaks for kids
who this spring were
isolated in homes where there was abuse
or domestic violence or just the trauma
of cover 19 health issues or over 19
economic issues and now we go into a new
school year where we're going to see
those same socio-emotional challenges so
we're in a tough spot as a education
sector
and if you were sitting in in your old
job as secretary of education right now
and obviously what you just described is
absolutely true ideally we would have
really solid contact tracing and testing
et cetera et cetera but given where we
are now
what would you be doing as secretary of
education some would argue that you know
there's only so many levers at the
federal level from from an education
point of view but but what levers are
there
yeah well really three things one is
the secretary in the education
department should be fighting for
resources for schools
if the federal government doesn't step
forward with significant
stimulus dollars school districts are
going to end up making layoffs at this
critical time um if there aren't
stimulus dollars we can't address the
digital divide issues there's a proposal
in congress four billion dollars to
expand the e-rate program so that
schools can help families get
access to the internet we should do that
we need congress to step up in that way
and we need the secretary of education
to be fighting for resources for schools
and for our most vulnerable kids that's
one two uh we need to lift up best
practices what are great examples of
people doing distance and hybrid well uh
what does that look like you know the
secretary has an incredible bully pulpit
and could be sharing those models from
around the country could be lifting up
districts like the phoenix union school
district in arizona that has every
student every day campaign where an
adult from the school district is in
touch with every kid every day just to
make sure they're checking on them
seeing if they need food or wi-fi
hotspot or help with math
um and then the third piece is
guidance around navigating some of these
public health considerations you know
what what should school districts be
thinking about uh
rates of community spread and when
should they make decisions about
opening or closing what should they do
when there's a case within a school
building how many cases
should they see before they make the
decision to close back up
school districts need guidance on these
things we have 13 000 school districts
each making these decisions on their own
with with very little help from the
federal government
and taking those one by one you know
your first point about um the funding
situation or at least trying to close
the digital divide giving access is this
feels like something that's beyond
politics it feels like it's a no-brainer
we're putting a trillion dollars into
each of these rounds of stimulus is is
there a counter argument or are people
just reticent to
i mean it seems like a small percentage
not even a percentage of the amount of
stimulus to get everyone access
yeah i mean you know i think as as
always happens when there's an economic
crisis there are people who make uh well
if you'll forgive the social studies
teacher reference there are people who
make the hoover argument you know we
have to do less we can't help people
um
i think that's exactly wrong this is an
fdr moment we we should think about
internet access the way
we thought about electricity in the new
deal and we had the tennessee valley
authority we had this massive national
commitment to make sure people had
electricity because you needed to
operate in the 20th century economy well
now we need the internet to operate in
the 21st century economy it's how kids
go to school but it's also how higher ed
students go to college it's how folks
can get access to benefits it's how you
look for a job today
we really could be doing more on this
front but again there are folks who who
want to say well because of the
financial crisis from covid we just have
to uh
give up on our aspirations i think
that's exactly wrong
it makes makes a ton of sense i mean the
part that makes tons of sense is that we
shouldn't be giving up
on your second point about guidance i
mean that that is something that i feel
as well that if people just had some
direction on what solid distance
learning can look like or hybrid
learning looks like that that in and of
itself and you know we're trying to do
what we can given you know what limited
voice we have
you know that example you mentioned in
in phoenix is fascinating i'm i'm
actually surprised i hadn't heard of
that yet what other best practices for
any educators out there listening or any
parents who are maybe in a position to
help influence what their schools are
doing what best practices you have you
been seeing that you think need more
amplification
yeah yeah well i'm so grateful for what
you're doing and what your team is doing
to try to make resources available
that's critical uh some things we're
seeing you know baltimore city for
example is doing this project where in
some schools they're having their
strongest teacher deliver the sort of
full class lesson while the other
teachers play more of a
tutoring and support role for students i
think there's an opportunity here for
creative staffing where people can play
different roles and you sort of leverage
people's talents we ought to be doing
more of that in this moment
there are school districts are being
very intentional about the supports kids
need to do asynchronous work well and
you know this from from from your work
there are set of skills around setting
goals managing your time asking for feed
for
help and feedback when you need it
acting on that feedback when you get it
those kinds of independent learning
skills are not necessarily something
that every classroom is cultivated
pre-covered and so an intentionality
around teaching those student agency
skills is really important
that's something a network of schools
called leap is working on in chicago for
example
there's
the opportunity
to sort of emphasize relational work and
this is a real challenge but kids
need relationships with peers and so
you've been thinking about something
small like how do we use breakout rooms
in zoom so that kids are working on
projects together how do we make this an
opportunity for connectedness rather
than isolation for students
some school districts are doing a better
job
trying trying to think about how do we
create projects that kids are working on
and keep them engaged
it is not enough to just say we're going
to do exactly what we used to do just do
it on zoom that is not a strategy
effective strategy for distance learning
you've got to say how do we use these
new technology tools to make learning
engaging and to help support students in
their social development as well as
their academic development
couldn't agree more a lot of what we
talk about is
you know ironically distance learning is
for a lot of kids their main connection
to socialization right now
so it's not just about the academic
standards we've got to make some way for
for kids to get connected i have a
really fascinating question from youtube
susanna garcia dominguez is saying in
light of the pandemic what rules need to
be rewritten
uh is is there a moment here where maybe
there are some constraints maybe some
rules regulations that exist for good
reason but uh you know but maybe are
slowing down a rapid response that we
could we could loosen temporarily
yeah i mean look we certainly i think
need to think flexibly about school
schedules to make hybrid work to make
distance work uh
to create opportunities for students to
have a healthy relationship to
technology and you know we can't expect
a first grader to be in front of zoom
for eight hours right so we're gonna
have to think differently about about
the schedule
we're gonna have to think differently
about how we engage parents parents are
gonna have to have a much larger role in
a distance learning context and so it's
not we're not gonna be able to get by
with just the you know the twice a year
parent teacher night we're going to need
regular communication with families so
that they understand how to support
their kids learning uh
we're going to need to maybe start to
think about more competency based model
where when students are ready to move on
to the next level of work we allow that
to happen i think about
the northern virginia community college
and virginia which
this summer offered every high school
junior and senior in their region the
opportunity to take a college course for
credit um
you know senior year is not always well
used in every high school and so let's
let's get students into college courses
let's let's accelerate
their progress where we can
and then as i mentioned some flexibility
around staffing roles uh
thinking differently about
how we use teachers time if someone's an
amazing
presenter of lessons that's great but
maybe someone else is better at the
one-on-one small group support for
students and let's deploy people a
little bit differently that's going to
require creative scheduling and creative
staff management
no i love i love those ideas and you
know what one of the things that we've
actually worked with long beach school
district in southern california it's
this project it's actually outside of
khan academy it's called
schoolhouse.world where there's one
version in the school district where any
teacher can work do group tutoring
sessions or group classes with any
student in the whole district so it
seems to rhyme a little bit with what
you described but i really like what you
like what you talked about which is a
division of labor a little bit where
yeah there's the lecture get the best
lecturer to do it but then get every all
the other teachers really that i would
say the more important work of that
human to human connection that that
tutoring that unblocking
i i'm curious
you know i think we've been talking
about ideals which it sounds like we're
very aligned on how do you think it is
going to play out over the coming year
uh you know what could be the damage
what's going to need to happen
let's say nine months from now a year
from now when things get to a little bit
more normal
yeah
well we're certainly going to need to
make up ground i mean the reality is you
know this because of digital divide we
have school districts where a quarter of
their kids didn't participate
at all last spring didn't log in
that's a disaster
mckinsey did a study recently suggesting
that the average learning loss or
unfinished learning would be seven
months
nine months for latino students ten
months for african-american students so
we're going to have ground that we need
to make up
that means when we get back to bricks
and mortar and
and hopefully move past covet
we're going to need to think about it
extending the school day extending the
school year we're going to need to think
about high dosage tutoring which has a
very strong evidence base
there's a proposal in congress from
senator coons to double the americorps
program so that we can match let's say
recent college grads with students to do
intensive tutoring
i think that that makes a ton of sense
and is very smart the uk and the
netherlands are also thinking about a
national tutoring core kind of effort so
we'll need that academic support we'll
also need to address some of the social
emotional impact i think we're going to
need more investment in school
counselors school social workers mental
health services for kids and for
families we've done polling at the
education trust uh showing just very
very high stress levels among parents
particularly low-income parents
particularly parents of students with
disabilities who are sometimes
struggling to provide
the supports their kids need at home so
uh we're going to need to kind of make
up for a lost time uh and some of the
harm that's come from this coveted
crisis
do you think that's doable let's say we
were to shift from a hoover mindset to
this fdr minds that you've been talking
about is that doable at the federal
level or does it have to happen at the
state or local level
well we certainly need federal
investment you know we we think it's
going to take at least 175 billion
dollars just to prevent cuts in school
districts but then on top of that we
need investment in this tutoring effort
extended learning time social emotional
supports but then we need leadership at
the state level the local level and the
school building level
for folks to say it's not just enough
to go back to business as usual we've
got to make up for the impact of covid
on kids and we've got to acknowledge
that we had disparities big disparities
big inequities particularly around race
and income before covet so going back to
normal is not good enough we actually
need to define a more equitable more
just future and that will require
leadership at every level
and
do you think there could be any silver
linings here that because of the crisis
certain elements are getting accelerated
i mean you talked about some good ideas
that sound like good ideas in in any
context you think those things will last
do you think we'll come out of this
better in some ways
with the right leadership i i think
that's possible you know some some
things i hope will stick one is i think
people have seen that technology can
create access to opportunity that kids
couldn't access before so you know we
have high schools where there are very
few ap classes for example but we know
colleges look for those ap courses we
know they are often giving kids an
opportunity to get college credits that
make college more affordable
but now
if you're in a high needs rural
community you didn't have ap classes in
your school but now you see through
technology you can actually have a
distance learning ap experience
hopefully we will close the
advanced coursework divide between some
of our schools coming out of this i
think parents and teachers have had to
collaborate in ways that i hope will
stick
the parents have have
gotten a window into their kids learning
experience and teachers have gone into a
habit of more communication with parents
at least in some districts hopefully
that continues and then i mentioned this
issue of student agency students can do
really cool stuff when given the freedom
and opportunity to do it so
as folks have had to move from maybe a
teacher-centric model
uh to a model that blends the
synchronous and asynchronous they've
gotten to see that oh well i can ask
students to to do this research project
on
how other countries are grappling with
covet and kids do this amazing work well
now let me let me shift my class so
there's more student agency more
opportunity for students to define their
learning goals and work with their peers
to produce
collaborative projects so i think we
could see some some positive benefits
but first we need the kind of leadership
to step up and get the resources and
deal with the media crisis
now this is super helpful
you know in the time we have left we
have a lot of young people who watch
this and i think it's always interesting
when we get high profile guests like
yourself to just understand your journey
i mean you you started off you actually
mentioned a few things that i did not
know that it sounds like you got you
know the early stages of your life with
your parents um
passing away sounds like a pretty hard
start
i'd love to know kind of your arc like
you know how did you go from there uh
what was the context like to eventually
becoming
secretary of education
yeah yeah well you know school school as
i said really saved my life
both my parents were teachers in the new
york city public schools
my mom passed when i was eight october
fourth grade i lived with my dad my dad
was quite sick with undiagnosed
alzheimer's so homeless is
scary and lonely and unstable
but school was amazing i i had an
amazing teacher in fourth of sixth grade
who did all these creative projects we
did productions of
midsummer night's stream shakespeare in
elementary school we went to the museum
and the ballet and he just exposed us to
this whole world beyond canarsie
brooklyn
and that made a huge difference for me
because i could be a kid in this
classroom when i couldn't at home
my dad passed when i was 12. i moved
around different schools different
family members but it's always teachers
who gave me a sense of hope and purpose
but like many young people who've
experienced trauma
by the time i was in high school i was
getting in a lot of trouble and i
actually got kicked out of high school
the first u.s secretary of education had
been kicked out of high school
but i was very fortunate that there were
teachers and a school counselor
and some family members who saw more
hope and potential in me than i could
see them myself and they gave me a
second chance and they invested in me
and helped me get my life back on track
and i ended up
having the opportunity to go to harvard
for college and there i got involved in
public service volunteering working with
young people i always encourage high
school students college students to
think about service how can you
share the blessings you have with others
and so i got involved in tutoring
programs summer camps
while in college and that
showed me how
fulfilling it could be to try to be the
kind of difference in kids lives that
teachers were for me and so then i
became i'm curious
i mean something you mentioned which was
fascinating and as much as you're
willing to share
what you got you got kicked out or
almost got kicked out of high school and
then it sounds like a few years later
you ended up going to harvard i i i'd
love to double click on that i mean as
much as you're going to share
where where were you what were you where
was your mind
or if you're willing to share why you
might have gotten kicked out and then
how was that turned around because i
think so many kids are on that
sure well you know i i was very angry as
a teenager angry at adults i mean it may
be irrational but i was angry at my
parents
angry at the things i went through as a
kid
angry at adults in my family who i felt
like didn't step in
and i think now in retrospect i realized
i didn't really know the scope of what
it was like at home and it was just my
dad and me i remember my dad was quite
sick i i mean
our house was crazy i had to figure out
how to get food in our house how to keep
our household going and i and i thought
someone should have stepped in and they
didn't and so i was very angry about
that and i was angry about just rules i
didn't i didn't want i've been on my own
since i was eight i didn't want anyone
telling me what to do uh so when i when
i got kicked out
i thought i thought my life was over i
thought well now you know i won't be
able to go to college i won't be able to
do anything
um
but i'd always done well academically i
mean the irony was i'd always been
really passionate about learning
and so
really a school counselor convinced me
you know you got to make the case that
you
have learned from the choices you've
made you've learned from these
experiences and you're ready to make
your life different and so i actually
had to write two college essays the
regular essay and then there's a special
essay you write if you've been kicked
out of high school and you have to
explain what happened and what its
impact was on you
and i was very lucky that you know
college admissions officers were willing
to take a chance on me and were willing
to see that i had learned from
the mistakes i'd made and and and wanted
to be different and contribute in a
different way
wow and so i i mean that's a fascinating
story i think it'll be inspiring for a
lot of kids
you know i was the lead singer of a
heavy metal band so i understand a
little bit of that teenage anger but but
you you you are even tougher
circumstances but it was as you i
interrupted you you were going you know
upon graduation how did you go from
there to you know career in education
and eventually secretary of education
yeah yeah so it really was you know the
the public service experience uh as an
undergrad at harvard i spent a lot of
time in boston in
public housing development where i ran
after school and summer programs
and
i just got passionate about how i mean
just like you right just like your story
right there there's something so
fulfilling about helping
young people uh learn and feel
successful and feel empowered and so i
love that and so that drew me to
teaching and so
uh first i was a high school social
studies teacher in the same neighborhood
where i'd
volunteered as an undergrad in boston
and then i became a middle school
principal
and i loved the work day-to-day with
students um
but i also wanted to think about how do
we move policy so that we create more
opportunity for kids and that's what
drew me ultimately
to working at the state level and then
at the federal level and having the
chance
to become secretary and it was such a
privilege
to be a part of the obama administration
president obama and mrs obama are just
so passionate about education and the
difference schools can make
in kids lives mrs obama has this really
powerful story as a first generation
college student she still commits
significant time to working on education
issues which is an initiative called
reach higher that i'm involved in it's
about helping high school students think
about their post-secondary plans
president obama is still involved in my
brother's keeper which is focused on
supports for boys and young men of color
so their their depth of commitment uh it
just was a pleasure to to work with them
and to be a part of the administration
and um
you know and now and then trust
i have the opportunity to be an advocate
and um
sort of join arms with other civil
rights organizations with parents with
educators with students to demand
something better and
you know we really have these two
pandemics now we've got pandemic of
covet 19 but we're also having an
important national conversation about
the pandemic of systemic racism that has
been a part of our country from the
beginning and so it's it's inspiring to
be a part of a movement to make real
change to make our society more just
no and your your life arc is inspiring
on a lot of levels there's a really
fascinating question maybe this is a
good question to
end on
is from facebook marcel davis says
as parents what should we be asking or
demanding of local education leaders you
mentioned they have a lot more agency
now how can they drive what's right for
their their children
yeah
it's a great question
we have a lot of resources on this
question at interest.org but uh but a
few quick observations one is um
to have a sense of where your kids are
to to understand
you know are they
are they on grade level are they behind
do they need additional support how are
they doing in math and reading and
science and social studies um so an
understanding of where your kids are
critical
um
you should be
alongside your child demanding
real engagement in learning it is not
enough to just have a kid sit in front
of zoom for hours while folks talk at
them and so
you want to be demanding that your kids
are really engaged that they're getting
interesting assignments if they're
reading interesting books that they're
having conversations with their teacher
with peers um
they should be having a real
learning experience and we know that
distance learning it's challenging but
it is possible to have that real
engagement
and then the third piece is that the the
socio-emotional dimension and the
creative dimension yes we've got to
focus on kids academics but they also
need to have relationships with peers
and teachers that morning meeting in
elementary school where the teacher just
checks in with every kid and they get to
see their peers that can for some kids
be the best part of the day so we have
to make sure those social emotional
supports are in place we have to make
sure there's creative time um we still
need the arts and we can still do the
arts through distance uh we can still
create opportunities for students to um
to paint to draw to make music to make
videos of their own right we should be
cultivating that creative side even as
we
try to grapple with making distance
learning work
so i i i hope that parents are really
pushing
their school districts to deliver
especially in communities that have been
underserved and we we all have a moral
responsibility to make sure that every
kid gets a high quality education
regardless of race regardless of income
regardless of zip code
no couldn't agree more well thank you so
much for joining for this conversation i
hope this is the first of many uh
conversations i i i hope we can also
collaborate on on on the ed trust khan
academy side of things but this is a
real honor thank you so much
thanks for the conversation thanks for
all you're doing
awesome well well thanks everyone for
joining us as you see another
fascinating conversation uh the time
always goes by much faster than i
expected to do when when we're
enthralled and getting some really
interesting uh wisdom uh but with that
uh encourage everyone stay safe uh
remind you know reminders as the school
year is starting up go to khan academy
we have get ready for grade level
courses as secretary king had alluded to
these are ways
you know to identify where your kids are
and if they if they're ready for grade
level if they need to fill in some gaps
they can obviously learn at their own
time piece on on khan academy i also
encourage folks to go to
schoolhouse.world which is the side
project that i'm doing with a ton of
volunteers ironically you know we heard
secretary king talk about how important
tutoring can be
ironically on school hot dot world we
have a lot of really great tutors who
are waiting to tutor you or your
children or or someone else's children i
guess as well uh so go there uh there's
a lot of capacity for what i think could
be really really compelling uh
experiences for a lot of young people
where not only will you get more support
above and beyond what you already get
from khan academy but you can also get
some interaction with folks really
around the world which i think is pretty
cool in a safe environment so thanks
everyone for joining and i'll see you i
believe in a day or two uh where we're
gonna do an ask me anything oh sorry no
this is wednesday tomorrow uh we're
gonna have uh representative karen bass
super exciting so uh please join us for
for that tomorrow
see everyone later
you